our next guest grew up in England came
across the pond to attend the University
of Houston on the golf scholarship
lasted all of 10 weeks before launching
into an incredible professional career
he won 41 tournaments but 30 of those
came in Europe so I guess those do count
they did invent the sport he was ranked
number one in the world for 97 weeks in
total which is pretty amazing after
retiring became the leaf lead golf
analyst for CBS in addition to looking
like Harrison Ford as far as I know the
only guest today who was been knighted
please welcome sir Nick yeah hey guys
there you go very good hey it's a
tradition unlike any other that because
respect for my man Tom broke my bro the
new six oh I didn't know that Tom Brady
was your bro well and so I thought it
seems it's at a discussion panel we
should discuss okay
wherever Tom six Super Bowl rings up
greater than my six majors Oh Oh discuss
among yourself as well like talk to Dan
okay but you get four tries in a year to
win a major oh wow my own fourteen
curves of caddy and I got to stand up
and hold the darn thing come on she's
possibly more impressive Nicklaus or
Brady Nicholas's majors but I think
still Jack I mean because of the spare
even a great to spend Jack's 18 majors
look at his he was 19 he was second
nineteen to he was 50 he was 53 times in
the top three you look at Jack's record
you go you're kidding that's not
possible you know and so now I think
jack is still the yeah the greatest well
mr. Federer is now Wow was he 20 okay
and then Serena's their terrain
oh yeah they're all we're on their
fields put them yeah it's what you're
here for to discuss that to have a
that's how he makes his living and it's
just discussing what we do what we all
do you know or did but can you quantify
the greatest athlete of all time because
some have physical yeah sure like the
resume Jack nobody was guarding him or
nobody was trying to kill him and so how
would John eonni was trying pretty hard
so no it's a good point I mean you
always that's you're always gonna argue
everybody would lean to what their sport
is you know without our event was for
over four days you've got that whole
mental factor of going home with the
lead and coming back whereas many sports
as you know where I ever
I guess tennis could say that that's
over two weeks to win Wimbledon same
seven gotta win seven matches so yeah
hey it's whichever way whichever way you
like to lean on your favoritism yeah do
you think about your wounds or your
losses wins luckily I'm very fortunate
I've lost a few majors but I'm really
fortune I thank the golfing guy I'm not
scarred by my losses which is really
nice you know I wouldn't like to have
had had a Van de Velde here in my career
if I gave you one do-over one mulligan
yeah well I'd love to that US Open that
was a cut those two US Opens actually
the when I lost him the playoff the
Kurdish strange was way back that was
over 1988 so I was at one year open in
87 having a good start
when you open win the hew s opening win
the mom in a good start you career and
then and I hit the hole at I wouldn't
mind he'd hidden the hole holding that
but I hit the hole on the last green at
the Medina open 1990 I'd won the Masters
hit the hole to tie and then I won the
our open at San Andres so oh I would
love to hold that maybe one the place
out of an even better serve three majors
in a row so but yeah as I said I'm very
great you could have got knighted sooner
I think if you
yeah yeah everything I'm very grateful
for the timing of everything yeah do you
get a suit of armor or yeah we do
actually yeah you get you get a suit
about an even better deal is there's a
there's a dry cleaners in Windsor with a
queen and you get you get 20% off when
you take your suit of armor in yeah but
do people like when is it okay to not
call you sir Nick Faldo when is it okay
to no I think you should start the day
we're calling meets a neck yeah kids do
kids do the sir do they Maki a line my
kids like when they come to breakfast
morning how you doing
what do you want for breakfast nothing
have you ever golf with anybody in the
royal family yes I used to play I used
to play a lot with with Prince Andrew
and I told you about the royal who's the
last time oh yes yeah but we haven't
that's time flight I haven't played golf
with him for moons I have to I'll have
to give him a call what if Prince Harry
called and said hey I'd love to yeah I'd
like to introduce all these young little
these little Royals to the game ago
that'll be cool we need to get all these
little tots into the game of golf that
would be good I think they might they
might be interested did you care if you
were liked when he played he took care
if I was like what I think you I had
that I gave off an air that I'm told by
you know sports psychologist that I had
a very enviable quality of being out to
be totally engrossed in what I was doing
so people on the outside would think
that was aloof cool cold ass whatever
they wanted to call me so I I was I I
believe that was the only way I could
play
was do you know real head down blinkers
on be totally engrossed in it and I I
couldn't handle distractions from the
outside and that's what I loved the fans
they're being played I love the
atmosphere absolutely so I enjoyed that
and I think the fans were there really
enjoyed watching me play obviously they
loved seve they loved him and his
character and everything I think they
respected me the way I play golf and I
enjoy that years later when people come
up to me and say well I Wow I jumped on
the train and throw and went all the way
up to Scotland went to Muir field watch
you win the Open went back home and and
and then they go do you know that was a
greatest day of my life and I think Wow
so that's a very you know heartwarming
sort of feeling to think that little 15
seconds to people that they watching me
play Goffman meant so much to some
people you know do you care of people
like you as an announcer well the
feedback is fantastic I mean I I really
enjoy being here in America because a
hundred percent of the people come up to
you and say well yeah I loved you
playing golf and oh I love you was
announcer now and I love this and then
they remember a few lines or you did
this and when I did my Bryson Jimbo
glasses upside down all this sort of
thing people don't get whether I'm being
silly or wherever um you know some
people say oh that's so disrespectful or
listening out I get the guy I like the
guy no it's my way of if I teed the
might as I said more I tease somebody
more I like him that's Johnny Miller I
don't know if he changed because I don't
know how you guys felt or you felt when
Johnny Miller was critical of of how you
played yeah but he did play and I don't
know what impact he had on golf where it
feels like it's okay to push a little
bit where before it was kind of hands
off here in the United States yeah yeah
yeah I agree you kind of just commented
what but the viewers want a little bit
more so we do try and spend a little bit
more time to get to know the person and
you know night you know you call shots I
mean if it's a good shot I like to tell
of you why it was a good shot and
obviously four guys shanked it I didn't
the tree you've got to tell him why it's
a bad shot but you don't have to get
personal on the blazer Bojan I like to
think I'm being factual if anything I'm
kind of throwing out lessons at all the
time so we try this do that he did this
stop doing that sort of thing so um try
to I think I get on great with all the
guys I mean I think sure I'd say as I
said if if they ever think I'm teasing
them a bit too much well it's only
because out of respect and I Michael
Moore has anybody challenged you here
one one one came and said because I said
that was the most stupid decision you've
ever made in your life he did take eight
at the whole so I kind of feel like I
was you know going in the right
direction so what are you gonna get
physical it was just oh no no no get
physical me um I'm training to fight the
Evander Holyfield so don't don't mess
with me man
yeah but he's 60 so I'm 62
Oh in the summer I'm 62 in July I'll
take you okay who's the PGA Tour player
currently if he came knocking on your
door and he had a problem with you you
probably with me negative this morning
don't worry if some had a problem with
me yeah well I don't unfortunately don't
mike apke comes through the door
oh yeah oh yeah he's the juggernaut
isn't that Wow they're just these guys
are big dudes as strong make us strong
what I love though is it's hard to to
play a certain way and and because I
don't know how much you are is an
entertainer
everybody's an entertainer mm-hmm but I
don't think you played to entertain as
much as you played to win that's true
and a lot of guys play to entertain and
you know so there's a little bit more
flamboyant yeah yeah what did you have
an entertainer in you that like you up
well yeah I think so my dad my dad left
his amateur dramatics a who's he an
actor Pam to mine actor yeah sort of
thing for a bit of fun
no that's why I say that my dad was my
dad's line and so I I've always been
good telling stories with my friends
used to love Hamlet joke but as I said
when I got on a golf course I went into
kind of serious mode this is what this
was priority this is how to here
I needed my full concentration to hit
this book I wish now and then I got a
great friend sports psychologist friend
who then said with my mental strength he
said I could have trained you just
bounce in and out where you know here's
the shot but you got a two minutes off
and there's a kid over there eating his
potato chips go over and steal his
potato chips whatever come back click
back into goal and I'm like well yeah I
wish I wish now I had that so you were
bit more liked or loved or whatever but
I think as I said I'm pretty real real
respective for how I played the game yes
but I think it's more of a nice record
it's my early morning Co wait who's
calling you know it's my little it's
just delicate alarm too you know because
I'm such an emotional petal good morning
friends hello say hello friends when you
see a shoot every time hello friends
come hello comes in the air we're going
over to his house today
are you ready we're gonna do the par-3
get him - ok cool get him - he does the
Jim Nantz omelet yeah you know make
something yeah you could put a problem
in she goes to the fridge door and when
opens the door the red light goes only
does 45 minutes so did you ever have a
strange thought over a pot like I know
you're always locked in but did you ever
have one of those where you know strange
what like don't miss this but something
where you're thinking about your kids or
dinner or no thinking your kids is
actually good for you because they you
know get back into the psychology they
look they say you get yourself in a warm
place and usually the warmest place is
to think of your children your children
and then you think are now nice and calm
and peaceful now I gotta face this
downhill left-to-righter
do an amazing so no generally holding it
you know
what the hell you you've got to do and
why so yeah you're kind of completely
engrossed in now then you wander off and
I'm in between shots you you worry about
your dinner reservations yeah Oh was it
last year when you talked about tiger we
weren't sure what we would see yeah well
I thought amazing yet I thought it to
sum it up he he learned so much you know
he would have a player couple of
torrents learn from it come back play a
little better a little bit a little way
through and then he could've got to open
car no see and then he's suddenly lead
him why I never thought that was gonna
happen then and then he found it
difficult to finish it off and and of
course learnt again from that got very
close unbelievable golf to the PGA
wasn't at that front and I couldn't hit
planet Earth yeah and he's 2-under and I
thought well if he can do this he could
win he could win now he's just got to
stand up and it's almost like but Kepler
was just mentally and physically
stronger and he just fended him off
brilliantly so that was very impressive
and and then the win at the end of the
season kind of just made sense it was
you know thirty man field he got to the
top sure we played great tourney and
he's just fending him off like the good
old days and that you know the scenes
were unbelievable problem with golf
that's five months ago now we'll get a
little bit on yeah that's forever I
remember when Tiger used to you know go
three weeks without winning that was
called a slump now you got a gear up
again he played um Tori two weeks back
getting the rust off he's playing
fortunately playing next week a trivia
we see a lot with Seymour but hey I
think it's we you're back to light here
we go again I'm a golfer I'm a I am
slightly better than the average bear
sure but he's going to get the rough
stuff again it's gotta go through the
whole process of how good's my game how
good's my nerve how good's Mizpah so
it's a hard grind in as you get older
he's Nick Faldo he'll be on the call
this weekend with Jim Nantz on CBS the
AT&T Pebble Beach pro-am
we always appreciate that you lead us
off that you get here early and now I
don't know if you want to hit balls or
would you just give us a putting tip
during the commercial break or if you'd
like to punch
of us if you think we've gotten too
negative here today yeah no I think you
want to hit ball oh yeah oh you don't
want to go hard
that looks too that looks too delicate I
mean that's alright we're gonna see that
the NURBS gone as I try no okay
I saw the claw working I see welcome
back and the man who introduced us to
the swing thought of Gianni honey mint
Ernie L Miller Ernie no no you don't
want her knee elves it's too quick
no he's great Ernie else Oh seve biters
almost as silly but yet Tiger Woods go
some speed he needs to speed we'll take
a break sir Nick Faldo will want to stay
with us hit some balls we're back after
this in the Dan Patrick show just tell
me what you said about your your grip my
I manipulate my right I move it at an
impact would you do rotate or supinate I
but I I'm of it a little bit so I close
the face well that's just called
rotation now you hit the light like the
Charlie Miller Johnny man you like that
last year no these guys got on the range
yesterday and they kept turning else
that's a lovely one
Adam Scott sees you to think of your
arms we did this last year Adam Scott's
ago and Adam Scott you think of your
arms don't you miss this yeah yeah and
then you do and then you can do her like
joy Jason Day is good with your belly
Jason Day oh that's weak
Nik the problem is I do this Brandt
Snedeker we can do Colin Montgomerie too
short
did you ever remember last year I did I
do you whipped on one didn't you
now I did that I did my Rory McIlroy
okay here we go remember Rory McIlroy
it's the lake and then you okay all
great God Sergio Garcia have you ever
had one of those moments we've killed an
old snake in a bunny look more like one
of those turtles Dino laying eggs on the
beach in Madagascan going everywhere
good job on that one yeah for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]